Now, a relative maximum is a value of the function that is higher than all the
other values of the function that are in the neighborhood of that point. So, a
so-called relative maximum like a relative minimum because it's a maximum just
in relation to the points surrounding that point. So, as we said before, B on
this purple curve is a relative maximum, that's because all of the points to the
left of it and all the points to the right of it, in the general area of the
curve close to B, have values of the function that are lower than what we find
at B itself. So, if we relate B to parts of the graph that are further away,
like points up here, we will find some areas where the function takes a higher
values than it does with B. But those aren't close by. For the points that B
really cares about that are close to it, it's right on top.